i welcome you all to the first
orientation session for post graduates
for omixlogic amity university uttar
pradesh collaborative training
we recently oriented the graduates for
omixlogic training and research and now
we are excited to orient you all
and bring you the benefit for the
collaboration between amity university
noida and pine biotech where the
objectives of this collaboration is to
increase the awareness of biology as
data science to address the urgent need
to encourage train and mentor people to
leverage available public domain data
sets and tools to explore the world of
biology
my name is sunali kari and i am the
omixlogic community manager i am
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of
our bioinformatics community that is
managed by pine biotech
so before we begin with today's talk i
would first of all like to introduce us
we are a based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs
are a result of close collaboration
between pine biotech and numerous
academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
we are pleased to announce that we also
recently collaborated with amateur
amity university jaipur china group of
colleges mahali mit pune and faba
federation of asian biotech associations
omixlogic training and research is
running internationally in eight
different regions and over fifteen
thousand users around the world
due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
omixlogic programs follow a
project-based learning approach which
use research grade tools to analyze data
from top peer reviewed journals
or mixed logic training has been
completed by participants from 162
countries in over 300 workshops for six
different specialization tracks
being oncology infectious diseases
precision medicine neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
omixology training and research
sorry for the glitch i'm honored to have
been working with a team that
collectively has an amazing experience
in this area including the other
co-founders of the company dr alfred
tauber who comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of trouble
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brodsky is the director of
tribal bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a hard work by some of
the people mentioned here on the right
julia panna who is an expert
bioinformatician and helped prepare many
of the materials that we would use avi
ditovsky who is a computer scientist and
leads the development of the t bioinfo
platform that we would use dr harpreet
core has an expertise in the application
of statistical machine learning
techniques on biomedical data and the
development of prediction tools and
databases and she looks after the
curriculum development bioinformatics
and data science course development as
well
dr mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
over the past several years he has been
developing collaborations with
universities as a mentor and project
lead for omics logic training and
research fellowship
dr raghavendra lakshmi narayan is an
accomplished computational biologist
with experience in large scale analysis
of multi-omics
and data science methods in precision
oncology and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
applying his proficiency in using python
r and shell script for bioinformatics dr
raghavendran is interested in
translational approaches to understand
cancer biology neurological disorders
and plant bioinformatics
as students embark on their professional
journey with freshly completed degrees
they often wonder how professional life
will be different from studies
many prepare for this moment in advance
exploring possibilities to work in an
area of interest through internships and
research fellowships during their
studies
amity university noida recognizes the
need to enable students to participate
in such meaningful experiences early on
leading to a pursuit of collaborations
with industry
as a result there is a natural fit
between amity university noita and pine
biotech a big data analytics company
that is focused on bioinformatics and
machine learning for biomedical data
as a result find biotech will work
closely with amateur university noida to
develop a pipeline for students to get
training and apply their bioinformatics
skills in research and industry projects
as interns and research fellows with the
company
this process starts with a program
designed to introduce students from all
backgrounds to the intersection of
biology and data science and we call it
omics logic
now to discuss about the collaboration
and the programs i would like to pass on
the stage to our mentors
i would like to invite dr mohit mazumdar
who has completed his phd in
computational biology and has been
working with academia and industry to
solve important research problems in his
current role he is working with students
and faculty and scientists who have keen
interest to explore biological data to
do research in bioinformatics and
provide guidance and training
over to you doctor mohant
thank you sunalika
and hello everyone
it's really nice to see you all let me
share my screen before i start my
presentation
okay as people are still joining uh
i would just want to give another
round of uh
introduction especially for those who
are joining for the first time
so uh
my name is mohit and i have completed my
phd in computational biology
and i have been working with academy and
industry for past several years
on important research problems
and one of the reasons
that
we have collaborated with
amity university noida
uttar pradesh is the reason being is to
be able to develop research
projects and develop training for such
research projects to
be carried out by students
um in a group
so today i wanted to discuss a little
bit about that uh but before uh telling
you about the process
of how this uh is going to helpful in
ntcc trainings and how this is going to
be helpful
and overall overall in your career
i just wanted to explain a little bit
about my experience uh how i got here
so uh i did my graduation in
bioinformatics and then i did my masters
uh from jamia and my phd from geology
university and then i went on to study
uh
at
cambridgeshire embl
welcome sanger institute and then i also
went to canada you know university of
saskatchewan
uh for uh research internships
so uh that was my academic career and
during that period of time i was able to
collaborate with a lot of faculties
but obviously before that when i was
doing my undergraduation and my master's
i was
not knowing so much about what what is
going on in the industry i was not
knowing much about the opportunities
that are really there
because uh
the important thing is that it is it is
to understand that how the industry
operates how the research you know works
how the areas of life sciences and
biotechnology works
so to knowing all of that
there's a need for you know industry
academy collaboration and there's a need
for students to get exposed to industry
and that's the reason we are here and i
am hopeful that we'll be able to help
you
uh with all of that in the coming months
as we uh develop these relationships and
develop research ideas and projects
along the way
so um
to tell you about this uh i think it was
a historic uh
memorandum of understanding
uh that was signed between amity
university uttar pradesh and pine biotec
us for joint research and trainings uh
in the area of uh bioinformatics data
science and computational biology
and i'm really really glad to meet you
all i'm going to say it again because uh
many of you are those researchers who
would be collaborating with uh us and
would be working with us
and uh developing really exciting
projects in several areas of research
that you're gonna hear about in the next
few minutes uh where you will be able to
understand uh train from a very basic
level and then get an understanding of
developing research projects using a
team of bioinformaticians and experts so
as i was telling you that this was a
breakthrough because uh there was a lot
of expertise and experts involved in
such a collaboration so we have over uh
50 faculties and over
a group of technicians and experts from
top of bioinformatics research center
university of haifa israel so uh topper
bioinformatics research center as
explained by sonalika as you have seen
is a
is a cutting-edge bioinformatics
research center
so we'll be obviously connected with our
bioinformatics research center along
with the faculties that we have in amity
university and the great researchers um
that we have at uh around the world
collaborating through this omix logic
research training
so um uh this happened between uh
several institutes so i met you
institute of biotechnology uh noida and
lucknow center for medical biotechnology
center for plant and environmental
biotechnology center for biotechnology
and biochemical engineering center for
cellular and molecular
biotechnology center for computational
biology and bioinformatics so the
discussions the breakthroughs were done
uh majorly by professor malvinder shukla
vice chancellor amity uttar pradesh
professor seema bhatnagar assistant
director coordinator ntcc and amity
institute of biotechnology
so as a result of this collaboration
what we are expecting is that ability to
provide high quality
bioinformatics education and continue to
expand with
a wide range of sophisticated tools for
new students
who are entering this dynamic
environment of you know data science and
bioinformatics and that's why we are
meeting with you all and we are
discussing this great opportunity that i
think all of you are going to appreciate
so as a result of training it is not
just training it is training and
research and developing skill sets which
are really really relevant to in today's
world that includes you know finding
collaborators
amongst faculty amongst mentors and
amongst other student groups that we
have that i'll be introducing you very
soon
so uh the first part today we are
meeting for the orientation and the
first part uh is to understand that what
are the different resources that we have
and today we are going to in the next
stage
of this presentation uh mr nalik is
going to help you with that so we are
going to review uh basic concepts of
genetic uh genetics uh basic concepts of
biotechnology and how modern
uh biology is uh now
been evolved from all of that and then
to develop a clear basic concepts of
bioinformatics and data science what are
the different keywords that are going to
be used what are the different keywords
that you would see that
industry and research
are you know putting up for the job
opportunities for the internship
opportunities and for you know uh going
for higher studies in uh
well top universities like harvard
cambridge mit and many other great
universities that are there
around the west and also in the east so
uh the thing is that we are going to do
is in this orientation part we would we
would want to learn about some of the
basic things that are going to build up
to that uh different stages that we
discussed where we are going to learn
about the technology where we're going
to learn about the application of the
technology and then when we we are going
to talk about you know how do you do it
yourself how can you become a master of
this
so this also involves like you know
application of r and python
that are really used in today's world
for analysis of this big data and then
how to gain how to use these tools and
algorithms in a systematic manner in a
meaningful manner so that you can you
know come up with solutions uh our work
at a work on problems such as you know
drug discovery and
yeah drug designing using machine
learning deep learning and all the
chemic
gaming informatics um tools that are
available out there
so um the uh the collaboration uh as
such uh is for the omics logic research
fellowship and this research fellowship
is a great opportunity to build a
research ecosystem between academy and
industry where we are going to address
challenges that are that can be
addressed through your uh you know
skill sets that you have developed as a
biotechnologist as a data as a you know
understanding how biotechnology is now
moving to become you know data science
biomedical data science and all of that
so uh today we are going to use some of
the uh resources that we have put
together for this innovative training
and that involves a couple of platforms
one is learn omixlogic.com that you can
see on the screen another is server
t-band for platform so the
learnomixlogic.com
that we are going to explore in some
time helps us to understand um
how do you how do like understand the
basic concepts of biology and then
builds up to you know different advanced
concepts and modern concepts uh where we
are talking about different type of data
types that are you know generated from
these experiments in the vet lab and
then how do you analyze that data using
this powerful multi-omics platform which
is the server t-band for platform where
you will be able to you know run the
experiments
on the cloud by uh using lots and lots
of data so we are talking about big data
so we are talking about data in
megabytes and gigabytes
so uh one of the reasons again i'm
coming back to the reasons uh that why
we are doing this so you know the
collaboration between industry and
academia is key to catalyzing innovation
and growth
so industry partnership is instrumental
in advancing research and in creating a
skilled workforce so in this era of
growing research cutting-edge
technologies have provided life-size
researchers to study this overwhelming
data at a molecular level and that is
why it is very important to understand
this
that the spike in this data which is
like spike in genomic data spike in gene
expression data spike in proteomic data
metabolomic data and data sequencing dna
sequencing data which is the genomic
data
has an enormous potential and an
enormous potential to solve some of the
most complicated challenges where life
science and computers act as a balancing
bridge in providing solutions to the
scientific questions and that's the
reason we are uh
providing
this omixologic research fellowship
so as i said you'll be utilizing some of
these resources and then there are
different steps so there are different
steps which includes basics which is the
topics that those are the topics that we
are going to cover uh during the basic
training where we are going to learn
from the resources that are put online
that you can take on your own convenient
time and do it at your own pace and then
we have a lot of recorded videos
by experts short videos that explains a
certain experiment that explains a
certain method that you can obviously
learn from and then we are planning uh
several live sessions hands-on sessions
on-site on online sessions to uh
help you go through these different
steps because we understand that
everyone ha are coming from a different
background everyone has a different
research interest so we are providing
this opportunity to be a more of an
individualistic
personalized help to develop research
topics that interest you the most
and then there's a
there's a feedback system that we have
prepared uh in collaboration with your
faculty and uh the
researchers who are there at the topper
bioinformatics research center and also
like the university collaborators and
our team in the us and also in different
areas of the uh different
locations uh around the world so uh
obviously there are different state
stages leading to different outcomes so
we'll be discussing them uh later so
what are the different advantages that
we are going to talk about is i already
discussed self-paced learning and the
big data platform and this project-based
curriculum and then we have the expert
mentors and we have different
collaborators from around the world like
one of the collaborators that sonalika
talked about is the faba faba is an
organization where we have collaborated
to design in in collaboration with
industry experts coming from big pharma
and coming from ai driven drug discovery
companies
to collaborate with us and enable and
give that knowledge to the student so
that they can understand that what is
going on and understand that how drug
discovery or you know chemi informatics
and and biomedical uh data analysis all
of this makes sense it with the advent
of technology and with the solutions
that are there providing to the
customers and those customers are all of
us because i think uh healthcare and
all the drugs that have been developed
by pharmaceutical companies and other
companies are being utilized by
many of us
so uh that is about that and then we
have uh the platform that our people
that we are going to discuss so there
are a few things in today's presentation
so i'll be quickly going through about
the different topics that you can choose
from and become specialized in
and then we will have uh short
presentations by dr harpreet and dr
raghav
who are here with us uh to discuss about
uh the projects that would be
that we would be working on and then uh
as i was telling you that why we are
doing this because yes biology is now a
little bit different than what it was
before because now we are not doing
single single experiments we are doing
high throughput experiments and when a
system which is capable of doing high
throughputs you know experiments then
the
amount of information that you get from
this high throughput experiments
becomes really really big
uh so that information that information
is one of the
major challenge
for anyone to you know interpret from
because data generation as you see
is becoming easier and easier uh you you
know load a sample from any environment
and put it in the machine and most of
the things are done automatedly and you
get the data but once you get the data i
mean that's where the you know that's
where the challenge starts so that's why
biology has now characteristics of data
data science and that's why this is
relevant so not just one two three four
five but billions
billions of data points that are just on
there on genes billions of proteins uh
expression expressing uh in different
organisms uh all around and at different
time points and these in this
information you know what this
information is compiled in large large
files that are available online on
public repositories and that's where we
are going to utilize that information
and make the most by
doing some scientific
really in-depth scientific research
applying some of the algorithms applying
some of the techniques that are there
right now are used by scientists all
around the globe and understand human
health understand you know living
organisms understand biotechnology
understand crop understand livestock
work on oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience agriculture and all those
fields
so uh some of the keywords that you got
that you need to learn about
that you must have heard about of course
as these simple keywords like you know
learning about omix technology dna
sequence in sequencing and dna sequences
is genomics you all have heard about
atgc you know how
are you know
at a string that uh runs uh those lines
are so long uh that a human genome
becomes a 3.2 base per billion base pair
long genome similarly like
transcriptomics protein structures these
are all interconnected and
the understanding of all those important
components are
you know nowadays are going giving us a
clear picture of how the system looks so
i'm talking about system biology here
i'm talking about you know problems that
are associated with system uh and with
uh with all of these things that are
that we are seeing around so i'm talking
about you know variants i'm talking
about mutations i'm talking about
viruses i'm talking about pandemic i'm
talking about the effect so uh all of
that is like related when we are looking
for solution strategies when we are
looking for you know techniques that can
help us do efficient drug designing or
at least help
the community by providing right kind of
results that can enable them to come up
with such a discovery to come up with
such an intervention that actually is
going to help humankind so that involves
utilizing this data analyzing this data
using techniques such as you know
machine learning and deep learning so we
are learning about this different type
of omics data that contains a very
detailed information of genetic
information sorry about the last slide
so yeah it contains a very detailed
information about the genetic
information and what we don't realize
when we learn about and hear about these
techniques is that okay this is a
technique and we get to know about this
information so what
you can ask that like
what is different like how this is
changing things this is changing things
because because
when i'm talking genomics it is like a
complete map of all the dna that is
there like entire
you know map of all the dna that is
there in the organism when i'm talking
about you know transcriptomics
epigenomics it is about the entire gene
expression profile of the of an organism
at a given point of time so
20 000 30 000 gene expression you're
looking and then you have a chance to
compare and when you do comparison
uh
yeah as i was telling you that when you
do comparison
then there's this probability you know
to
to work uh or understand different types
so one person is having cancer one
person does not have cancer you do the
comparison you see what is out there
what is different and you come up with
some new thing so that's how it is i
mean nowadays we do a lot of comparison
we're comparing the data that is
available with the reference data and
then we are understanding so many
different things
uh so that is a lot about bioinformatics
that how bioinformatics is playing a key
role by you know analyzing the data
comparing data and this is really uh
doable now
so after getting oriented about all of
this you know basics like what are the
different data types what are the
different technologies and what are the
different applications like getting an
overview you next the next step is to
learn about some of these technologies
so you can choose like if you want to do
like if you're interested in like for
example cancer and finding mutations
that
are causing the cancer then uh one of
the technology that you can use is
genomics right uh similarly there are
different technologies for different
research questions that can be answered
using that so the data that is being
generated the information that that data
is giving is something that you can
discuss with the experts right here all
of us are capable of answering such
questions that what this technology can
be applied for is it capable of
answering your question whether the
there are data sets available to answer
such questions all of that so i'm
talking about these different
technologies in the next step after you
get oriented you will be learning about
these different technologies and how you
are going to learn about these different
technologies you are going to learn and
experience the hands-on so you will be
seeing the data types you'll be seeing
the information and then you'll be
practicing on these different data types
and understanding that how you can apply
this technologies without you know uh
needed need to learn coding so we have a
platform that is an ai guided platform
which you'll be seeing very soon that
would not require you to you know do
coding but once you understand the logic
that how it works uh how this entire
uh
analysis pathway goes what are the
different workflows that are there
you can then
you can definitely if you are interested
you can learn coding as well because the
platform is capable of handling uh
python r and doing downstream analysis
so if you are interested in coding you
can go for coding but if you are not
familiar or if you are if you don't want
to do coding then also you can do all
the analysis and do good biological
interpretation out of your data by that
but yeah we would recommend you to you
know because it's like connected and
it's very easy to do because we already
have everything prepared for you so we
would recommend you to go one step by uh
one step to another step and explore all
the resources that are out there because
you never know what interests you more
what interests you most and maybe you'll
find
them really nice to carry forward uh
with your skill sets
so i the reason uh we are doing this is
because there's a huge need there's a
huge gap and there's a lot of demand for
people who have data analysis skill sets
in u.s
when you apply for a technical position
or when you are done biotechnology or
just applying technology and when you
have data science skill sets there is a
2.5 percent you know
higher like fold higher salary that you
will be applicable to get when you have
both the skill sets so you you data
science skill sets are really adding to
that
part
and similar to the that of different
industry so research industry is where
you can apply this hospitals are using
this pharma is using this for sure
and after you learn about all of that
the
next step is to learn about different
specializations that are out there so
you can learn on uh different data types
that we have and examples that we have
prepared for you that involves all of
these projects that are available on the
portal
for you to take online
and
this can be done through
the
steps that uh sunalika will show you
very soon so um now once you have
learned about the introduction once you
have gotten into the understanding of
you know what are these technologies how
they can be applied on you know you you
have learned it by applying it on
example data sets so you learn on you
know how uh the ebola outbreak happened
and what analysis we could do
for understanding the outbreak that
happened in 2015 2016 in west africa uh
that example was there which i showed
you in the last um you know presentation
last slide but once you have learned it
like you can think about the questions
that you can answer you can think about
the questions that your faculty is
working on and how you can help your
faculty to complete some of the analysis
that he's planning to do and uh maybe
come out with a publication so those are
the real opportunities that we are going
to present to you that are going to help
you enhance your uh profile enhance your
curriculum
enhance your cv so that you can showcase
that and obviously we have an online
platform that actually showcases all of
that that could be seen by anyone who is
interested in hiring you
so uh
the future of medicine i was coming to
the specialization the future of
medicine is
precision medicine
and we discussed in length about why
precision medicine is important and
today in today's talk um
dr raghavendran is going to talk about
his research on precision medicine and
how
the different type of other omics data
is actually enabling
scientists to understand how this can be
useful for individual at an individual
level so precision medicine is an
emerging approach for disease treatment
and prevention that takes into account
in the about
about account of individual variability
the variability could be at a genetic
level at your in your genes so
genetically i can be different from you
because there's specific difference in
our gene and the environment that we
lived in so
today i'm little under the weather and
one of the reason is
i would i should say not under the
weather i should say under the pollution
so pollution uh i'm in delhi so there's
a lot of pollution here and uh i'm
having allergies right now so this is
the environment that we are living in
that has an effect on our body right to
consider that environment is to
understand that how this you know how
you can sample some of the data that is
there in your gut so metagenomic data
can be used to understand that how it is
interacting our gut microbiota is
interacting so all of that there is a
gut
project gut microbiome project that
happened in the us that you you're going
to learn when you learn about
metagenomics but going back to you know
precision medicine it is important to
learn this because it gives you a you
know understanding of basic and
translational research that could be in
oncology that could be an infectious
diseases neuroscience and especially in
cancer there's a lot of work that has
been going on especially because it's a
very complicated disease and we all know
the recoveration of what happens when a
person is being diagnosed with cancer so
bioinformatics is
a huge huge plus
uh in today's world for finding
solutions especially for precision
you know
when we are
talking about different type of data
analysis that happens at different level
so when you start a drug discovery
pipeline you start by you know
testing your drug on patient derived
cell lines first you do it on cell lines
then you do it on xenograft mouse models
where the tumor is implanted where
doctor herbert is going to talk a little
bit about this in her presentation today
and then how you do it on a clinical
level
to get that information so at different
stages you will find data and then you
can see that how this is you know
working for different companies and how
some of the drugs got approved through
this process uh by fda so one of the
reasons that cancer can be you know
helpful by uh by
by us by a bioinformaticians who can
help our data analysis analysts like all
of us here who is going to work on these
sort of challenges is to help them by
early diagnosis by getting you know um
by finding new biomarkers or signatures
molecular signatures for early detection
and prognosis so uh also like because
cancer is a disease of aging the more
we're growing old the more the chances
are there for such mutations to happen
so if if we can properly screen an early
diagnose we'll be able to save a lot of
people
so i was going to tell you about one
short case study so this is that case
study and then we have emr studies and
similarly in infectious diseases uh
there's a lot of opportunity our team is
working on you know finding genomic
sequences differences in the genomic
variants and host
immune response so if you have any of
the infectious disease project in your
mind you can obviously
think about that and can work on such
topics similarly there are different
topics within infectious diseases and
i've already told you about metagenomics
that how metagenomics plays an important
real role in understanding the natural
environment dissecting these communities
exploring
species richness and then finding those
microbial community for human health and
disease and then we have exciting
opportunities where we are integrating
all of this data and finding that what
is the uh outcome of such studies what
is the best that we can get and
similarly after learning about all this
you have an opportunity to do work with
a project which is driven more towards
drug discovery more towards you know
finding drugs by using this information
that you got by the omics data by using
you know maybe some of the faculty have
already found some drug uh or sorry
found some target which can be you know
which could be a druggable target so we
can obviously plan to find
targets and
find
noble drugs by involving hit discovery
and you know do some optimizations using
ai
similarly we are working on
we are going to work on uh finding new
protein structures what which can be
like protein not new protein structures
but uh finding structures that we can
you know fold uh and predict using um
maybe google's deep mind uh
the software that they came up with uh
when the 14th uh crisp critical
assessment of structural prediction
competition
so these are some of the opportunities
to you know explore maybe do some alpha
fold prediction compare it with some
other molecule or do complex prediction
such as that so we are going to be uh
discussing and doing uh proj research
work in all of these areas and we
welcome you all to join and be a part of
this opportunity and get started with an
orientation and get you know really
familiarized with such an interesting
areas of study that are available for
you to take and undergo this sort of
training and develop research project
using the mixed logic research
fellowship so that involves spaceomics
that involves you know learning about
astronomers astronomers health that
involves you know working on
complex problem and all of this is
simplified all of this is really what we
have been trying to do is to simplify
all of this and make it uh in a way that
anyone absolutely anyone without a
background of bioinformatics without a
background of you know computational
coding languages can do this on their
own so uh
obviously i would like to welcome you
all again and uh really appreciate all
of you joining today and great to see
you all and if you have any questions
for me please put it in the chat and for
the first uh orientation
uh meeting uh now i would like to ask in
uh snalika to take you forward to the
learn login and show you the advantages
of building a profile and going through
the initial coursework as a part of this
orientation followed by that we will
we will be able to meet also
uh dr
harpreet and dr raghavendran for their
project information thank you
thank you so much dr mohan so now i
would like to take you all to the very
same landing page where you all
registered yourself so by registering
yourself you might have noticed that on
the very same learning page you can see
a stepwise process that we have tried to
streamline uh to get you all started
with the training and then move ahead
with all of your research projects
right so now let's get started you all
need to visit the omixlogic learn portal
and sign up now once i say sign up you
all need to create a free
account so let's do this together i
would be giving uh
let's a five minutes time to you all to
sign up here is the link
you may find in the chat box
now once you have signed up on the
portal please let me know in the chat
box itself by sending in a one or yes
maybe so that i know that we can proceed
forward it is very important to create
an account so that you can get started
with the uh training
okay so now let me do this with you
either you can create your credentials
just type in your mail id create a
password for yes for yourself and sign
in or you can also sign up uh
by your social accounts it could be a
google account or facebook account
or anyone that you would like to connect
with so let me just sign up and show it
to you please put in the chat box once
you have completed your sign up
so as we are running short of time i
will now just quickly take you ahead
and others can sign up and also look at
whatever guidelines are being instructed
right now so once you have completed
your sign up you are requested to please
update your profile now having an
updated profile means that you must have
a profile picture
your name should be in title case
because this is the same font that is
going to be reflected in your
certificate
you must connect your social accounts
and also add a brief bio about yourself
so that we know what is your background
and what are your research interests
and uh all the courses that you would be
taking on the omixojic learn portal you
can see all of them here under the
courses tab on your profile itself
and once you complete the courses you
might be able to uh download a
certificate as well
from the profile tab itself
so i just wanted to give you a very
quick overview of uh one of your uh
fellows
profile whose name is
biotech student and i would like to
highlight his profile just to showcase
you uh what's what score he has and how
beautifully he has updated his profile
so as you can see taval has all his
social accounts linked and his name is
entitled case and he also has a brief
bio about himself he did complete a lot
of courses
i think you need to change the shipping
your screen
oh okay
thank you so much
so this is the profile i was talking
about
as you can see that all the courses that
he completed are visible in his profile
and also the project that he would be
submitting very soon he has submitted
the project in his scholarship he would
be uploading the same on the profile too
and also he can down he has already
downloaded and shared a lot of the
certificates on the social media
platforms
now why is it important to have a
complete profile with all the details i
mentioned it is important because we do
feature profiles based on their progress
so having an all the things updated is
going to help you share uh
your um
all your updates on social media and
also with each and every course that you
will complete on the portal you are
going to get some points and as you can
see double has already uh scored 19 000
uh points and has reached an expert
level
now let me
get you all started so once you have
registered yourself and updated your
profile with all the details that i have
mentioned
the next step is to complete the basic
training so before we start off
with the research
like with the research fellowship
program or before we start up
start off with your own independent
research project it's very important to
be well versed with the concepts that
are required to carry out that research
project to know what the concept is to
know what the methodology is to know
what the algorithms are how they're
involved and to get some hands-on
practice uh by by
running the pipelines also dr hartreet
would help you all to run those
pipelines and she will also give a
glimpse of one of those in today's
session
so uh now once you have completed your
profile then comes the basic training
part where you need to complete the very
basic three courses the first one is an
introduction to bioinformatics the
second one is bytes and molecules and
the third one is how to design a
bioinformatics research project right so
let's just go to these courses very
quickly and see what's in here
also
this is your first assignment so you all
are supposed to simply register yourself
complete your profile and just complete
these first two courses that i just
mentioned
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and molecules
and you must be able to complete
introduction to bioinformatics within uh
one week and the bytes and molecules
could be covered within the second week
so um
we are hoping that you all must be able
to submit your first assignment by the
end of the second week
so let's see what's an introduction to
bioinformatics
in this particular course you will be
able to understand the basics of
bioinformatics
so bioinformatics is not at all a
different field altogether but it is
actually a field that is integrated
these days in all the various uh domains
of biology be it biotechnology
microbiology pharmacy biochemistry you
can you will find a some element of
bioinformatics in the field definitely
so it's important to understand
what is bio information
important
we have already uh explained this in
detail why informatics is important so i
think let's move on to the tasks and
then pass it over right sir thank you so
much and the second course is bytes and
molecules and this particular uh course
is going to uh help you understand the
various uh
domains what uh so talk about genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics so here you
will find all the introductory lessons
where you can just
understand the basics and then proceed
further with uh
whatever specialization you might want
to proceed with
okay so these are the two courses that
that you have to finish and also make
sure that you have a complete profile
and just after this session i would be
mailing you out a form which has to be
submitted by the end of second week
where you have to just submit your learn
new id now what is a learn new id this
is your learn user id and uh we can just
monitor your progress again and make
sure that you have completed the
assignment just by visiting your profile
id so please make sure that you submit
your assignment here
now i would like to pass on the stage to
dr harpreet over to yuma
thank you so much and thank you dr mohit
giving the overview about bioinformatics
and this program
okay so now let me share my slide
hello everyone
uh so myself herpes and i have a phd in
bioinformatics in my current role with
buying biotech i'm curriculum developer
and research consultant
so where i'm meanting research follows
and working with international
collaborators in various research
projects based on biomedical and js data
so already dr mohit has explained you
and gave you overview about different
omics fields and their application
now let me give you glimpse
how bioinformatics can be used on
biomedical data to drive significant
meaning by taking some example process
so that i had completed during my phd
and completed with number of research
follows like you
so before we start working on any
project we need to understand the
background of that research question
so my phd was in the area of cancer
genomics specifically liver cancer so
when i went through the literature
to understand what are the major
loopholes associated with this
malignancy so i have observed liver
cancer is often a misdiagnosed and
detected too late for an effective
treatment
another factor that contribute to the
poor outcome of the liver cancer patient
is the frequent reoccurrence of the
tumor after the treatment
so with
keeping these concern in mind so i have
uh addressed some of the possible
research questions
so in the first project
we use large-scale transcriptomics data
to identify diagnostic biomedical panels
for a primary labor malignancy that is
hepatocellular carcinoma
so in this study
we used 30 publicly available data
a data set containing nearly 4 000
samples to illustrate transcriptomic
biomarker panel for diagnosis and
prognosis of liver cancer
implementing various
data mining techniques
so in the next second project
we focused on another liver malignancy
that is cleanser carcinoma so in this
study we use nine dataset containing
350 challengio carcinoma 133 it's in
non-tumors 90 hepatocellular carcinoma
patient sample to scrutinize clencho
carcinomas pacific transcriptomic
signatures
implementing various machine learning
techniques like extra t svm random
forest logistic regression etc
so in the next project
we focused on identifying the biomarkers
that can predict liver cancer at an
early stage
so in this project we use
transcriptomics and methylation data to
identify a biomarker panel for space
classification of scc
so here we use 350 samples
and eventually elucidate 51 bioma
feature based biomarkers which include
30 rna transcripts and 20 methylation
cpt site using various data mining and
statistical methods
so in the last project we focused on
identifying multi-atomic signatures that
can stratify
low occurrence
risk group and high reoccurrence risk
group of the scc patients
here we identify 90 rna 50 mi rna 50
methylation and four integrated features
so besides i have worked with number of
the research fellow with pine biotech so
many of these research fellows they
don't have much skills
in the bioinformatics or any programming
language
so how they able to implement different
skills and what they come up with so let
me give you some of the glimpse of the
project that were completed by our
research values
so miss
first we have missed semaitolana who is
an undergraduate student from turkey
completed her project entitled long
non-coding rna as a therapeutic target
in chronic lymphocytic leukemia using
publicly available data and various
tools that are integrated on tbalco
server that dr muys hal was talking
about and i will also demonstrate it to
you
then miss ujja parikh has completed her
research project identification of
biomarker to differentiate between
neural stem cell and glioblastoma stem
cells employing publicly available data
and using various bioinformatics methods
so then apart from the ongology then we
have another research fellow who worked
in the field of neuroscience
so here miss ruthvaja completed her her
project entitled in silico analysis of
transcriptomic profile profiling an
affected biological pathway in multiple
sclerosis
so then another very important field
that dr mohit was talking about is space
comics so then we have a research fellow
mr dilara de kane who has completed her
research project in the field of
space comics particularly
she worked
on a project entitled radiation threat
to human in space an alternative
approach with probiotic using
metagenomics data
and various bioinformatics tools that
are integrated on t-band for server
so apart from neuroscience and
oncology then we i have also worked in
the field of infectious diseases with
our uh with the research follows like mr
has completed his project in project in
the field of malaria in specifically
analysis of gene expression profile to
study malaria vaccine dose efficacy and
immune response modulation during
transcriptomics data of the pacing using
various data mining techniques
so apart from the transcriptomics we
also work on genomic data with ghana
team
so then uh besides
graduate and postgraduate or phd student
then there are some of the research
fellows who are just a high school
student
so like uh we have ms nitra universal
who has completed her process entitled
effect of onset of menopause on the
transcriptomic profile of easing female
brains
and then mr andres has completed his
project in the field of alzheimer's
disease particularly where he studied
myeloid beta induced
neutrophil activation may provide a link
between the two patholog
pathological hallmarks of alzheimer's
disease condition
so then we also work with the research
fellow from mit university as well so
let me just take you to directly to the
uh
on the learn platform where you can find
their projects as well directly
so let me just for share link with you
so they are also worked in various
fields including infectious disease
oncology and neuroscience
so for instance missed kanuba sharma
here completed her project on
bioinformatics analysis on small s
small cell lung cancer patient with moon
bone metastatist
using publicly available data then ms
acanxa then completed her project on in
silicon analysis of angiosperm of
glyoblastoma to understand the impact of
idh1 idh1 mutation and you can also go
through these videos to understand
exactly what they had done
so then we have uh mr aditya vajpayee
completed his project on transcription
analysis of hiv infection
then ms shruti goyal completed her
project on transcription analysis of
early detection of
cervical cancer
then mr hariday thakur thakur has
completed his project on identification
of biomarker for the prostate cancer
so far we are we were talking about like
how different uh research projects can
be completed by using research uh using
publicly available data and implementing
various bioinformatics techniques so now
let me give you the glimpse like how we
can do it
so let me just demonstrate it to you let
me take you to this t bandhos server
so here
we have different sub sections if you
have look at ngs data mask
spectrometry structure biology then
various data integration or data mining
techniques so then apart from that you
we have also specialized tracks on
in the field of cancer biology biology
genomics and epigenomics and mather
genomics so depending upon your research
interest you can explore these uh tools
and of course to understand how this
pipeline and analysis analysis tool
works you need to go through the basic
courses
which are associated with these kind of
analysis
so now let me
demonstrate to you by taking
one one example of pdx preset
so here we have how we can generate
simple gene expression table from raw
sequencing data so if you look at this
raw sequencing publicly available data
so we have like
128 sample where each file is like 4 gb
8gb or something like that if you you
want to process this data on your own
system it is not possible so how you can
process this data itself
uh by using these kind of platform here
so this particular platform will help
you to
understand this data how to process the
process and analyze that so i am taking
example of this data itself so where we
have nearly 128 samples and for from
which we have taken like already
selected desired 20 samples or so
so here i'm taking this pdx project so
what is
pdx those so these are the patient drive
genograph where our tumor freshly
tumored tissue is transplanted from
human to the uh immunodeficient mice so
here we have the data from breast cancer
where we have two types of breast cancer
that is er positive and triple negative
so to how we can process this data using
this platform so once by because this is
an example pipeline so we already
uploaded the data so here you need not
to do anything you just can click on ok
so by clicking on ok we will able to
upload the data
then here different
options automatically will get
highlighted once you uploaded the data
to understand which step you need to
execute that explanation is given within
the course but right now here i'm just
showing you like here we have to first
perform first step under the
preprocessing so here you need to
understand like this is the option that
i need to perform and how and what this
step particular step is doing so you
will also get details here as well so
when you click on the option
and for example this is trimomatic
so trimmomatic will remove adapters from
your raw sequence increase
so then we are the next step which is
getting highlighted that is ccr clean so
you need not to write any program so you
just need to do click and uh
click an option but before clicking on
or using an option you need to
understand the logics
so by clicking on ok i'm i'm able to
perform pcr clean which
will remove any pcr duplicates from our
data
so the next options which are getting
highlighted here under the mapping if
you look at these uh algorithms so they
are
under the mapping on genome or
transcriptome so here as i just want to
generate a ready to use expression data
set matrices so i am performing mapping
or alignment of
uh
of these weights on reference genome so
you will also get details here itself
like what this tool is doing
so then by clicking on ok we will able
to execute this step
then then once we able to perform
alignment of a reads on reference you
know next how we can quantify that so
here you will the option which is
getting highlighted that is rscm so this
algorithm will
eventually uh calculate the abundance of
your reach again for a particular gene
or a particular transcript so here we
able to act by clicking on ok we will
able to execute this step
then there is a two options getting
highlighted so this is for differential
expression analysis right now we can
skip this but i am ending just my
pipeline here by clicking on and we will
able to complete the pipeline
so here you will able to obtain
eventually these outputs so then how to
analyze these outputs because you
finally have clear gene expression table
so
those things you will learn when you
going through these different courses so
yeah now if you have any questions
please feel free to post your query in
the chat book
and i'm looking forward to work with you
so yeah thank you
thank you so much dr harpy now i would
like to uh call dr raghavendran to
please share about his research project
over to you dr raka mentioned
thank you very much
let me share my screen
okay
[Music]
first
[Music]
good afternoon to one and all i am
raghav indian bioinformatics mentor and
research consultant with ormix logics
let me brief you about my background in
research interests i am a computational
biologist by training and i specialize
in subjects like multi-homic data
analysis data science methods in
precision ontology and protein and dna
structural bioinformatics so i completed
my formal education bioinformatics and
biophysics and graduated phd in
computational biology from max
plantation germany then i worked on
projects involving catholic genomics
plant bioinformatics protein social
bioinformatics in the institute of
bioinformatics and applied by technology
bengaluru and at the javelina university
as a postdoctoral business scientist so
throughout the research career i
developed special interest and developed
my expertise in precision oncology
through data science methods applied to
multi-units data so right from my phd
years i have mentored several undergrad
students and i feel a privilege to work
with some of the bright young minds and
also post-graduate students like you all
in the past in the future so i wish and
sincerely hope that you all enjoy as
much as i do in this partnership between
america and find biotech usa
so that was a very concise view of my
background and research interests now i
want to briefly speak about one of my
such projects in involving precision
oncology i chose to talk specially
specifically about this study because it
utilizes a very well established
pipeline of multi-omics data analysis on
publicly available data so in the end i
hope this project will inspire you to
develop your your own scientific
curiosity leveraging the abundance of
publicly available data in the
platforms available
okay sorry for that so
we know that cancer is the leading cons
leading cost of the disease deaths
worldwide so for such a dreadful disease
a systematic cancer treatments involved
or have relied on simple
chemotherapeutic drugs that are
marginally more toxic to cancer cells
than normal cells this is a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond to cancer
drugs in comparison about 80 percentage
of the patients respond to popular
painkillers available in the market so a
prominent solution to this problem this
precision oncological therapy where a
treatment strategy is designed by
targeting the molecular characteristics
of the patient's tumor hence the
treatment is personalized to the
patients who are likely to respond to
specific cancer therapies
there is not sufficiently enough data
from cancer patients to molecularly
characterize tumors under multitude of
different treatment options available at
the market now so hence we have to sort
the suitable model systems
that was introduced to you earlier by
mohit dr mohit i'm also dr hatwith like
in cell line data and also in
immuno compromised mouse data which are
also called as patient-derived
xenographs
so
uh
this study involves data from patient
derives in graphs so i have already
covered why we have to do such a study
and let me go to how this is done so the
tumor cells from the cancer patients are
subjected to next gene sequencing
techniques and the information about the
genetic expression and the gene mutation
and copy number variation very extract
this data molecularly characterizes the
tumors
then these tumor samples are then
grafted into immunosuppressed mouse and
administered several cancer drugs the
tumors response to their respective
drugs were documented as a
tumor volume data and and the mouse's
survival response data
this data records the tumor's reaction
to different treatments that were
administered so both the molecular
characterization data and the treatments
response data are available along with
the publication such a wealth of data
generates a plethora on lot of research
questions
my specific interest using this data is
to design and implement machine learning
models to predict tumor responses to
different treatments available
so what did i find
so uh i
i find uh
the treatment responses predicted uh
that was predicted was more more
accurate when i use information from all
the genes compared to information from
single gene biomarkers that was
traditionally used so in the left most
part of the graph you see that
this plot
deals with a machine learning model that
uses data only from the single gene
biomarkers to predict the treatment
response of all the tumors so the second
graph it it
demonstrates you the accuracy which has
to reach at mcc value of one to be a
perfectly accurate machine learning
model has been to significantly when i
use the genetic mutation data from all
the genes available so furthermore if i
include more uh let me go to this yes so
furthermore if i include more omics data
like copy number variation and genetic
expression gene expression data so my uh
my consistency in the prediction
accuracy improves leaps and bounds as
you can see this spans a whole array of
minus one to plus one with no
consistency in prediction to when i use
samples from or when i use information
from all the mixed data and
compared to the single gene biomarkers i
get a very consistent prediction around
0.5 and above which is considered very
good prediction for such a sparse data
that is available
so
the accuracy hence i have just
demonstrated you the accuracy of the
prediction increased when more than one
type of sequencing data
were used to train the machine learning
model so what else could be done more in
such a study so the um
with this list of
information
informative genes
we can extrapolate that into gene set
enrichment analysis and try to identify
specific biomarkers that explains the
tumors resistance or the tumor
sensitivity to given treatment so one
can extend also in addition to that one
can extend such an analysis to include
patient data from the tcga repository
that would give us a sneak peek at the
performance of machine learning models
which were built and trained on
pre-clinical data like mouse immuno
compromised mouse data and
tested or but applied and tested on real
world patient data like the tcga patient
data and
so these are all the these are the
interesting research question that one
can extend
that my type this type of multimeter
integration analysis into
this this hope this was
informative and inspiring for you all to
generate interesting research questions
from publicly available data
to perform such an analysis coding is an
integral part but if one lacks coding
experience that should not deter you
from asking such such an interesting
questions and omix logics platform
bridges that gap by providing the
necessary training and platforms require
you to perform such an impactful
research and let me demonstrate you
why is this not working
okay great so
i want to provide you uh with the sample
of how lessons involving coding are
organized in the omics logic platform
these are some of the courses that you
will find in the platform and these
courses that involve coding are
organized and directed specifically
towards students who have completed the
introductory courses in their respective
subjects and all these courses have the
following organization in the part
involving executing r and python courses
the organization involves includes what
analysis are we doing
why are we doing such an analysis
and what do we
expect to learn from doing such analysis
and finally how do we perform such an
analysis the codes especially the r and
the python course themselves include
comments at each step explaining the
purpose the syntaxes and the variables
so it becomes very easy to follow
through and finally the output generated
from performing such an analysis and how
is this output interpreted with respect
to the biological questions in hand
so with that i i hope i i would have
inspired you to ask several
interesting research questions despite
uh lacking prior experience in coding or
expectation for it and if you are an
expert in coding we have several
several options available to expand your
skill and knowledge in the specific
areas
and with that i would like to conclude
my thought talk and thank you all for
your attention and hand over the podium
to miss analytica
thank you so much dr thakur
and i would just like to thank everyone
who joined the meeting and understood
about the amisologic amity university
training and research program i would be
now mailing out all the details to you
all it would be nice if you uh get
started with your first assignment and
be responsive by submitting your profile
ids thank you all once again for joining
today's session